hello and welcome to this video where I
think I should put this oh no this is
wrong hey welcome to this video I think
this is the best position for this thing
but it did not yet save us okay let's
get going in this rapid game on
unleashes playing a raging Tiger here
with the black pieces up and we got a
new zoo Indian with Queen to c2 yeah
yeah I can play various lines knight c6
was my web book choice not sure that air
flow adequately booked up in the other
variation so let's plate yeah let's see
I hope I can do a decent job here didn't
really have a good night's sleep it was
just too hot we should you fire and you
know this is I think not correct
the default ponder I mean why don't you
at least invest a couple of seconds not
playing g5 just for social father we
could have played maybe some sort of d5
and now this is just not working at all
we may form is running into Bishop d7
the bishop is not hanging due to Queens
it allows you to check now it's a big
big center pond not just any other pond
that's an important thing to take into
account it's a difference if you win a
center pawn or if you win an unimportant
relatively unimportant torn at the side
of the board why does he give me that
temple I mean this should be seven you
can argue about it doesn't really help a
lot but it is probably somewhat useful
okay and all the way back so what's
happening here I think well and I think
I just dropped back to f5 being ready to
take the bishop
okay so interesting ideas is e5 try to
play HOH form just trapping the bishop
down g3 I think that makes a quite some
sense so if I go h5 now he will probably
take in this case Bishop takes Queen a
fourth this actually loops the bishop
this is important is actually
threatening now to take and win my piece
so I think I'm going to take and now
probably h5 trying to arrest the bishop
with h4
Quincy - maybe nope
take that okay and now with this pin and
this is actually well played I happened
that something I have not really
appreciated for them
hmm I didn't I didn't really I didn't
really see that this Bishop takes and
Bishop each form has this enormous
enormous annoyance value running how
long I would like to play Queen to you
726 and then make the knight mobile
again it is a it is an awkward pin
really is I think he currently I think
cannot do all that much looks a little
bit shaky if the whole construction
looks shaky yeah I was thinking just be
six don't really see a problem with it
consume deeply annoyed by that pin maybe
he doesn't really have anything to to to
use this I don't see anything great home
the night on d2 is quite passive maybe
singing e4 and then that f1 is three
years it is quite slow I know I don't
see a tactic
I will click entry six and then move the
night almost almost no matter wat he can
try to pry open the air file with some
castles and their three maybe this is
actually a good idea
checking simply checking me okay Bishop
to d7 Queen moves and then then move the
Queen and then the knight him yeah doing
this with the tempo is making sense
Queen a six might happen no it just goes
back okay so here and we'll go Queenie
six I absolutely want to unpin this
thing I'm pin the knight castling I
would probably play Bishop c6 intending
97-95 that would be a good square if he
cannot somehow use that slightly and uh
pneumonias build up with the Queen on e6
and the knight on f6 if he had does not
have anything right now I'm next one or
two moves it should be very very okay
for me yes so do you stop it I think I
think I'll do stop it stop it
the a pawn because you know Bishop c6
1975 a4 is the target so I want to fix
that target don't want to allow him to
push the pawn forward to potentially
traded
could you six and sorry father
yawning it was written incredibly
incredibly tiring experience this night
somehow this night the night not the
knight on f6 but the night like darkness
and so on
it the night and okay so I can just go
here and I'm not sure I think Age 3
might just help me it doesn't help
doesn't help what I think ninety seventy
five will be very very nice to get in
and currently g2 is just hanging I mean
I was still a rather more afraid of
canceling at f3 trying to open this up I
mean the bishop on h4 is not so easy to
get rid of okay so here mmm
a couple of things but I think this is
good
the knight on c5 will be deeply annoying
Oh ticks with the pawn there I can
hmm Queen takes not such a bad idea
actually
we're in context extremely solid but
it's both pretty strong so Queen takes
should g3 h4 and it's also very good I
don't know they they both both
continuations are a lot better for black
maybe three takes or even a bit more
powerful jump not so easy to the same
the problem is I mean he has to play I
think we should be three eg 300k having
but not continuation sir they don't look
good anyway but Todd Bishop cheeks
efficiently three years a bit more
natural even though after f5 I'm
threatening f4 and it's not quite clear
what white suppliers yeah okay well here
the blunder of the default pawn was
already quite decisive so it's always
tough for me to understand why I mean
white obviously had no idea about this
opening and if you don't know anything
about it why play a place so quickly in
the opening and just think a bit about
you but your choices I mean you can be
reasonably sure that the opponent knows
it I mean I'm a title player and and so
on so why not invest a bit of time and
try to figure it out
maybe you thought is such a harmless
position there is simply nothing to look
at but gas been experienced there is
some bite with LexA set up the default
pawn is under pressure and Bishop h4
already was a problem yeah what is
White's doing now I have an extremely
nice control over the light squares f3
e-form yeah this is possible and the
question is do i trade here or not I can
go 94
Bishop if form he might take on c5 this
is something that you can do anyway all
1994 immediately it's also quite good
with c4 hanging and so on tough to say
let's make a practical decision whole
day and all continuations are pretty
strong
white cannot cancel Norman c4 is hanging
right away and then a four times
difficult suggest remove
yeah maybe 90 to get rid about rid of
the e4 Knight that's not a real solution
but you have to play something I mean
yeah but how do I actually continue I
would like to get books into the game
okay the age look at least looking at
this Bishop but look on a age doesn't do
all that much just canceling long would
be good but there's a bishop on aged
form maybe just King Jack in heaven also
it's a little bit you a little bit
spoiled for choice you can play many
things that will be good yeah kind of as
expected
if you check here and keen takes me who
takes you for is hanging I can also just
let him take it's also not bad
we should comes to the bishop comes to
2f 3 it will be terribly dominating or
even only four it will be very nice
clean f7 was to connect looks it should
be safe there on f7 I couldn't quite I
mean long cancelling you cannot do with
the bishop on h4 so it a king move is
probably best to connect the books yep
this is a fantastic piece of reform
yeah you will most likely cover the c4
pawn now with these three most likely
when I cannot put a look on there
already file is not so leaning so what
to do the easiest is probably to try to
win the c4 pawn which should be easily
doable with Bishop to d3 here win the
pole
now that place should be very good for
back don't see it defense to this
and then the black king is also and
potentially somewhat weaker than been
wine okay so here I take with the Queen
that's going to be sell that's something
I definitely don't want to see now Queen
to c6 is the most unlikely move and now
Liam problem going to CH cover c7 and
also be 55 intended to put it back on a
dominating square like before or f3
maybe you look to the one now to prevent
the 55 I also have pawn to d5 that that
would basically trade Queens that's not
a bad continuation actually just to
trade the quiz it's complete control
that a4s is extremely weak so okay I'm
happy to do this expel the Queen Queen
will drop there and now Bishop here with
the Queen a tool being an idea however
however then Queen to d7 is going to
happen that then I definitely have to
prevent
[Music]
as to be expected
[Music]
[Music]
okay here is a good square I'm thinking
about even Queenie eight to keep it
simple method there's absolutely no
reason to rush anything here White has
zero counter play and I don't mind you
try around a little bit and see what
happens
I can also play King g6 simply stepping
out of any e/m setting out of any Queen
d7 check ideas in case of my queen
moving
I can also just go c6
next you will not be able to take due to
rupee one so yeah also playing this a
bit quickly is helpful simply keeping
water Shaun White
so um I can play into b3 here there is
no trickery there is no check
I'm taking a four as well
now there's no you could move relief may
be currency to hoping for cream trays
even that is strong for black but I
wouldn't drag queens I would go to see
form dominating more maybe the movie for
is an idea to try to have actually a
that is a serious idea actually form and
after a capture Queen III
put them up playing against your phone I
have to take with the pawn right queen
III Queen b1 okay so I have to kick with
the pawn that's good to know
Bishop takes Queen is free isn't all
that clear now call me probably it
should probably win so probably win as
well that I will take with upon the
clean solution yeah while it's running
out of ideas a little bit Bishop e7 I
don't quite get the idea
after the screen capture on a form we
have an F queen a1 yeah I can actually
check you should be one enter Bishop
takes I think it's probably a bit more
precise
I have clue one also wins of course if
the six Bishop is hanging down so look
the eight this will check yeah and here
you can transfer this to our end game
with the rook up yeah so let's go to the
analysis board and have a look if my
conversion was fine it was mostly a
conversion because of the the opening
problems no I just get one line I'd like
to have three lines okay so can jump
back I also made some mistakes maybe in
the technical phase of the game so with
this and this is perfectly normal
however white normally goes step back to
t2 it makes some sense
usually you want to play Bishop d2 and
and Bishop g5 just provokes age six
sometimes having age six on the board is
a little bit of an advantage for white
for example g4 g5 just more interesting
or in some cases with h6 if you imagine
black playing g5 later there is a week s
v square this is all an idea with
provoking h6 a bishop h4 around into g5
and here why just clearly struggling you
will hear played relatively quickly I
think and d5 is maybe a bit more and a
bit a bit more testing yeah and then we
gifted me another tempo it's kind of a
little bit strange when you invested
some time and it's quite clear that I
played Bishop d7 I'm not going to go
back with the night or something just
winning winning a temple yeah here you
can play a couple of things the engine
wants to take on c3 then Knight f5 but
neither v immediately is okay as well
but we until h5 wasn't so precise them
yeah I think it's not what the engine
gives but I think it actually does give
the line yeah what the computer the
computer line is very very convincing
actually I'm preventing before the
bishop is on a strong square on c6 this
looks a bit better and then justice I
didn't like all that much relief oh no
way I did here yeah take you may be
better now here this is not so easy
yes I was slightly inaccurate for sure
uh-huh
I mean I'm so happy with the position
that that wasn't the best probably with
six cream beef I would also weird I'm
just giving me time now I have three
years something like that looks more
testing its evaluator that's just
slightly better feedback
why follow those moves down don't really
really allow yeah now it gets very very
nice got many squares to attack and some
very convenient choices this also looks
good but I didn't think it was as clear
as wanting a Christian ornate form the
night but this is just tempting square
king of seminary things that fancy files
better it okay it's a really totally
winning position and the only thing
that's really important if you have a
position that is completely overwhelming
just to not avoid any to avoid any
counter plan that you can avoid you
don't want to have difficult problems to
solve anymore I think it was it was
quite reasonable ooga ACH must match up
maybe yeah Lex pollution is all it's
just a lot of atom I computer finds a
couple of odd evaluate some samples as
mistakes that it doesn't really change
the verdict of your position at all yeah
white right into this opening is opening
mistake now you have to in that news
over the 96 then you have to mostly
decide between a 3 and X do this or take
with the bishop and in the inserting
this is actually quite useful so I'm
agreeing with everything but now we
should play Bishop to D 2 which is just
keeping the material and leads to a
typical complicated middle game where
why this may be a little better due to
the space ok guys thanks for watching